nach der veröffentlichung des marler
bericht sieht sich us präsident donald
trump von allen vorwürfen entlastet
keine behinderung der justiz keine
verschwörung
das gab es nie und wird es nie geben
doch so einfach ist es nicht
sonderermittler maler stellt in seinem
bericht fest dass es im wahlkampf zwar
zahlreiche kontakte des tram teams mit
russland gab
doch das material reiche nicht aus für
strafrechtliche anschuldigungen eine
solche mögliche verschwörung will maler
aber auch nicht ausschließen
mahler schildert diverse episoden die
belegen wie tram versucht hat auf die
russland ermittlungen einfluss zu nehmen
er lässt aber offen ob diese versuche
womöglich strafrechtlich relevant
gewesen sind die oppositionellen
demokraten haben maler zu einer anhörung
in den justizausschuss des
repräsentantenhauses eingeladen um noch
offene fragen zu klären